in japan und den usa ist sie ein star
dabei ist hat sony co nicht mehr als das
produkt eines computer-codes eine
singende illusion ein hologramm
ihre lieder komponieren die fans in
weniger als zehn jahren entstanden über
100000 songs mit dem passenden programm
und ein paar klicks beginnt hat zu dem
mikro zu singen
und ein paar wenige klicks später tanzt
sie bereits auch in deutschland tritt
sie auf die premiere ist anders sie
wollen zu verdanken
für ihn verkörpert die sängerin etwas
einzigartiges ich glaube mit herz ohne
mikro haben wir eine art von neuem
popstar digital animierte figur die von
den fans kreiert wurde gewissermaßen
natürlich ist die figur irgendwann mal
geschaffen worden aber die ganze musik
die ganze welt das ganze künstlerische
an dieser figur die ganz songs die sind
von den fans geschrieben worden und
dadurch ist es sowas wie der erste
demokratische wälster den es gibt
erfunden wurde dieser demokratische star
von einer firma namens captain future
media und diese verdient ganz
monopolistisch viel geld an hat sony co
sie veranstaltet konzerte vertreibt die
software und verkauft fanartikel
einen eigenen oder einheitlichen stil
hat dazu nico nicht sie ist nicht mehr
als eine hülle die jeder nach seinem
geschmack füllen kann
einer der vielen der zone micro für ihre
werke benutzen ist der japanische
komponist kate yoshimura in hamburg
gastiert er mit seiner pop oper die ent
die virtuelle sängerin war für ihn wie
eine muse ich mag keine diven
diese typische emotionalen sängerinnen
das kann ich für meine musik nicht
gebrauchen
bei hatsune miku spüre ich eine ganz
eigene art von romantik und
sentimentalität in der stimme sie klingt
sehr flach aber sie kann sehr spezielle
gefühl ausdrücken dem ich im herzen
berühren
die fans kommen nicht unbedingt wegen
shibuya sondern vor allem wegen freue
mich riesig
die oper erinnert raum doch an die
fröhlichen popkonzerte für die natur
nico sonst steht bei shibuya simuliert
das hologramm keine person die
möglichkeiten eines digitalen stars
werden ausgelotet
in der auseinandersetzung mit dem tod
konfrontiert hatsune miku ihr publikum
mit ungewohntem optisch musikalisch und
inhaltlich manche verließen die show vor
dem ende
andere waren begeistert sie war immer so
groß zu sehen und nicht so als mensch
wie man sie hätte darstellen können
ich bin erstaunt weil ich hätte nicht zu
nico eröffnet einerseits neue
möglichkeiten für die fans andererseits
lebt sie nur dank ihrer beteiligung ein
symbiotisches miteinander von mensch und
maschine